it's time for your questions and we hope
to answer them and we began to get a lot
of them Pastor go ahead the first one is
what does being a Christian mean to you
Pastor C.D Brooks
personal questions I'll give you a
personal answer being a Christian to me
means everything
that is positive and good in my life
it means that I got to marry my ideal
we're not a Christian I would never have
met this young lady
being a Christian to me means a family
that is secure and safe and close and
Christian
being a Christian to me means integrity
with security when the phone rings I
don't have to worry when I walk in the
mall no one need wonder whose hand I am
holding
being a Christian to me means peace I
can go to bed at night and sleep like a
baby being a Christian to me means hope
I'm glad this world is not the end this
is chapter one I look forward to chapter
two when somebody say Amen out there
that is living with Christ and his
coming is the Blessed hope being a
Christian to me means Better Health I
was given the opportunity to speak to a
convention
celebrating the 65th anniversary of the
high school I attended and I was there
and at the head table and big thing you
see and there were hundreds and hundreds
of people sitting around great tables
and many of them began to catch my eye
and wave and I wondered who are these
people
now if you think I look old you should
see them
what I'm trying to say is being a
Christian pays off in every way
being a Christian to me means everything
that is positive a friend of mine said
to me one day if there were no heaven
and no hell and if death was the end of
it all I'd still want to live a
Christian Life Next please
Dr Brooks in Genesis when God created
man is that the same as when he formed
Adam and Eve yes that's true when God
made that Adam and Eve they were our
first parents they were the first to
issue from his hand everybody else was
born these two were made by the infinite
God he made Adam and woman Adam means
man and woman she didn't get the name
Eve until after sin entered the world
and then she was called the mother of
life meaning that through her life would
come back to those of us consigned to
death
Pastor what are some of the ways we can
praise God and bring him glory and honor
I I think this is a provocative question
just hand it to us I think perhaps the
safest answer I can give is the best way
to praise God Is by giving your life to
him and living a life that is a sterling
witness for him
I think that comes ahead of preaching
and praying and testifying and singing
Because all of that is invalid unless we
are really converted but if we surrender
to God and become his and then live as
though we know it I heard a preacher say
if you are a believer in the Redeemer
then you ought to act like you are
redeemed and when we begin to do that
then we may praise him with testimony by
sharing our faith by witnessing for him
by singing songs of praise and by being
cheerful and sweet and kind the world is
looking for Christians who are kind and
when they find one they praise the Lord
has to suppose the only job a man can
find is to be a bar keeper would this be
wrong he has to support his family
and we fall into rationalizing
rationalizing is a sin for oh forgive me
rationalizing can be a sin because it
exalts human reasoning above the will of
God
That's Heavy but I wanted to say it
we who are Christians have got to come
to terms with this reality this is a
world of sin and we are pilgrims down
here
we cannot do just everything
now this doesn't pertain to a whirling
who is unconverted who has no respect
for God but when we claim to belong to
Jesus and become a part of his family
then there are certain things we can do
and certain things we can't do there are
certain things that if we do them they
are incongruous with our profession a
Christian does not serve liquor at the
bar
now having said that there's a text you
perhaps ought to read it's found in the
book of habakkuk habakkuk chapter 2 and
verse 15 woe unto them that gives his
neighbor drink
Mr evangelist I have been taught Jesus
only please comment
oh yes I I do realize there is a there
is this pervasive
doctrine that is spread across our land
there is some who become offended if you
mention the father and the Holy Spirit
they say Jesus only well let me quote
Jesus only he said go into all the world
and teach All Nations baptizing them in
the name of the father
and of the Sun and of the Holy Spirit
would you say Amen out there
Jesus said that
he prayed Our Father which art in heaven
when he said that he was on Earth
but one of the conclusive texts is found
in Matthew the third chapter the baptism
of Jesus the Bible says after he was
baptized he was coming up out of the
water one the Holy Spirit descended in
the form of a dove to and the voice of
his father was heard from Heaven saying
this is my beloved Son in whom I am well
pleased Jesus in the water holy ghost
coming down father speaking from Heaven
a god of the Christian is the Trinity
three gods in one don't be thrown by
that the Bible says when a man and a
woman get married and they really love
each other and are pleasing God the
tween Twain means to the twain become
one you still are two people you still
have your own individuality but you
become one in purpose One In Worship one
in planting the family one in spending
the money one in judgment one in
everything
next please
this person wants to know is it true a
child is not responsible until he is 12
years of age
no that's not true there's so many
things that are said
you remember the flood
and only Noah and his family lived
a lot of children die
the Bible tells us in Proverbs 20 and
verse 11 even a child is known by his
doing
so this obituary age of 12 is something
man has said god holds us responsible
for whatever knowledge we have
as soon as we acquire it a child that
knows not to steal at five years old is
held accountable for stealing if he does
next please
our last question for tonight you ask us
to have faith without seeing how can I
accept what I do not understand
well listen we human beings are limited
creatures I I said recently in a sermons
of young people that we can't even see
the present
we see the immediate past if I slap my
hand like that you think you'll see it
immediately but you don't your eyes are
lenses that pick up what I do but the
part of your brain that interprets it is
back here called the occipital pole and
your eyes are connected to this back
here by optic nerves which means when I
do that by the time it gets back here
you see the immediate past and since we
are so limited we are creatures of Faith
whether we like it or not
you came in here and sat down by faith
how did you know these wouldn't
collapse and injure your back
how did you know that roof wouldn't fall
in and kill you you're in here by faith
go to a restaurant as some did today and
they bring you your food and you just
start eating by faith how do you know
some nut didn't put arsenic in your food
you get ready to pay Uncle Sam his
income tax and you put a check in an
envelope put a little stamp on it and go
on some impersonal Corner drop it in
some impersonal box and you say I paid
my income tax no you haven't you put it
in a box by faith that the postman would
deliver it
ladies and gentlemen we have to believe
something
and when we say how can I believe what I
have not seen
we are not really being realistic
we do that all the time every day and uh
I heard an old evangelist say one day
there are a lot of things you can't
understand you can't understand
television but you watch it you can't
understand the telephone but you use it
you don't understand how a black cow can
give white milk
yellow butter
by eating green grass
but you enjoy it thank you for your
questions read to me from the Bible that
the gay lifestyle is wrong
well I'll be glad to accommodate you and
by the way I could read many things but
one of the most explicit will be found
in the book of Romans chapter one give
me a moment to find it and I'll read it
to you Romans chapter 1 and the Bible
says beginning with verse 26 for this
cause God gave them up unto vile
affections for even their women did
change the natural use into that which
is against nature and likewise also the
men leaving the natural use of the woman
burned in their lust one toward another
men with men working that which is
unseemly and receiving in themselves
that recompense of their era which was
meat
please don't miss the wording there from
inspiration
they do it
the Bible says working that which is
unseemly meaning that which is
incredible that which is unimaginable
that which is totally unnatural and then
the Bible says they receive in
themselves that recompense recompense
means payoff
your soul to the wind you reap the
Whirlwind
you cannot sin with impunity and those
who practice this reap what they have
done the recompense the Bible says of
their era which was meat and the word
meat there means appropriate and it goes
on to say many things about people
living contrary to God's will but when
you get down to verse 32
it sums up it all by saying who knowing
the Judgment of God that they which
commit such things are worthy of death
not only do the same but have pleasure
in them that do them
they not only practice it themselves
but they like to watch it on television
and read of it in magazines they get
pleasure out of others that do it
beloved we have no desire to make
anything wrong that isn't wrong
and the Bible thoroughly and soundly
condemns the sin of homosexuality
but Jesus loves homosexuals Sinners and
he will give them Victory if they will
to have it next please
you mind if I read one more
I I thought it was here it's First
Corinthians 6 9 and it says know ye not
that the unrighteous shall not inherit
the kingdom of God
and then it goes on to say be not
deceived neither fornicators
nor idolaters
nor adulterers nor effeminate
nor abusers of themselves with mankind
they shall not inherit the kingdom of
God what was this question pastor we
want to know here Pastor will we know
our family members in heaven if we've
all been changed oh my we're going to be
changed but we're going to know one
another that's what Paul said in First
Corinthians 13. then shall I know even
as also I am known I wouldn't want to go
to heaven and not know my wife
you're so quiet tonight are you quiet
because the president is here why don't
you say Amen to that you have loved ones
mothers fathers and many of them will be
in the kingdom of God and if you're
there you want to know them isn't that
right the Bible says we shall
Dr Brooks this is from a young person
why doesn't God answer your prayer right
away and you know it's something that he
would want and you know it's something
you would want
someone said God answers all prayers
God is a loving God the Bible says he
loves to give good gifts to his children
but some of the things we ask for are
not best for us
now I've had the experience but I won't
talk about my own suppose a little child
two years old came to you with a
straight razor in his hand
and said I want to play with this let me
play with this would you allow it
no the reason you wouldn't is because
being older and wiser you would know it
wouldn't be best for the child
God sometimes listens to things that we
ask for and he knows they are not best
for us do you know there's a text in the
Bible that says the Holy Spirit maketh
intercession for us
with groanings that cannot be uttered by
the human throat you might be praying
Lord give me a million dollars and the
Holy Spirit says no don't do that father
for if you gave him a million dollars
they would quit Church
I like what I heard so many years ago I
got to remember that God sometimes says
yes he sometimes says no and he
sometimes says wait a while
all our answers
next please
Dr Brooks tell us what does God think of
interracial relationships
well first of all let's not try to make
a racist out of God
he has no respecter of persons it is not
morally wrong
for people of different races to get
married it might be socially wrong but
not morally wrong is that clear
listen let me tell you when a person
becomes a Christian it should be that
his battle with evil has been decided
from that point on his decisions are
between what's good and better and best
would you say Amen
that's what wisdom is what's best
and so in every case you must decide
what is best there are certain pressures
but brought to bear upon interracial
couples if you can't deal with it don't
get into it
I like compatibility in marriage
but if you have chosen to love each
other and you love the Lord did nothing
wrong with it and anybody who says it is
is not telling the truth next please
Pastor please read to me the text about
our cruel husband's prayers because I
need that for my husband oh
my well we quoted it to you last night
and and in harmony with your request
we'll read it to you it should be in
First Peter 3 and verse 7 it says
likewise ye husbands dwell with them
according to knowledge giving honor unto
the wife as unto the week of vessel and
as being heirs together of the grace of
life that your prayers be not hindered
next please
another young person Dr Brooks when we
sin and we know we are doing wrong will
God forgive us when we pray and when he
knows we are doing wrong really what
does it mean if we are sorry if we are
not sorry when we pray
well first of all beloved young person
you cannot fool God he reads the heart
he knows even the intentions is that
clear
he knows the thoughts that you think
he knows us
to sin
and not plan to quit
and to pray on top of that is called
presumption
we got a sermon coming up on the
unpardonable said I hope you will look
forward to it it is a very dangerous
course to follow
doing wrong when you're no better
hardens the heart
and you keep that up and the Holy Spirit
might withdraw from your prisons there's
a text you ought to remember Psalm 66
and verse 18. it says if I regard
iniquity now now let's pause a moment I
I want to make a shade of difference
between trespasses sins and iniquity
trespasses are shortcomings sin missing
the mark that's what the Greek word
means but iniquity is doing wrong when
you know better
iniquity is planned to sin
and the Bible says if I regard iniquity
if I know it's there
the Lord will not hear me you're just
wasting your time but when you are ready
to quit he's ready to hear next please
our last question for tonight Mr Brooks
if my husband and I are separated is it
all right for me to go out with someone
else on a date
well of course it is
if your husband and you are separated
and and you want to go out on a date you
may go with Mrs Green
Mrs Brown
Mrs Jones
but that isn't what you mean
you want to know is it all right to have
a boyfriend it's of no no you are still
married
and until a proper divorce is in place
you do not have that right in the sight
of God is that clear
and you will be displeasing God and
pleasing yourself where the devil can
tempt you above that you might be able
to bear
beloved you have no right to that and
the Bible says so may God bless you we
appreciate your questions when people
keep doing me wrong do I have to forgive
them anyway
you know you know the disciples asked
the Lord that in Matthew chapter 6 the
Lord said or rather they wanted to know
how many times shall I forgive until
seven times and the Lord said no but
till 70 times 7 in other words he wasn't
even then
giving an exact time to cut off
forgiveness but rather keep on forgiving
as long as you are offended keep on
forgiving to be a forgiver is to be like
Jesus and when we pray the Lord's Prayer
we say father forgive us our debts as we
forget our debtors do you know what
you're really saying you're really
saying Lord don't forgive me unless I
forgive others as long as you need
forgiveness keep unforgiving it is the
way the Lord is next you'll remember
Pastor the other night you talked about
the proper kind of marriage yes this
person makes a statement in Iraq in
Hawaii right now it is legal for the
same sex to have marriage since all
states believe that we must honor the
other State's rights look at the
problems this is going to cause really
there is a higher law would somebody say
Amen to that there is a God in heaven
and what he says supersedes what men
vote God and his righteousness are not
subject to a human plebiscite When God
Says something that stands and you know
what this world is Bound for Destruction
and it's a sad thing to say but the
majority of the people in it will be
destroyed
therefore those who care about God have
got to regard his word and no matter
what the law says down here they will
respond to God's will
therefore we become individuals not
moved by States or state laws but
individuals controlled by the Holy
Spirit intent on obeying the word of God
well this comes from a young person is
it okay to listen to Christian rock
music what does the Bible say I used to
spend a lot of time on College and
Academy campuses and I used to get a
question what's wrong with rock and roll
now frankly I have read uh quite a bit
about it and could give you a clinical
answer
now
Christ and Satan do not work together
as far as I'm concerned Christian rock
is a contradiction of terms if it's
Christian it ain't Rock if it's rock it
ain't Christian
amen Now ladies and gentlemen here is
the best answer I could give you and the
answer I started getting on campuses
rather than talking and talking and
talking about all the things that have
been tested and proved I have one answer
when you are thoroughly converted
the holy spirit will give you a distaste
for the things of the world and a love
for the things of God
when you are converted you won't even
have to ask a question like that
the holy spirit will tell you next
please
Dr Brooks this question came right
before we came on the Rostrum tonight
Leviathan a sea monster spoken about in
Psalm 74 Isaiah 27 job 41 who or what is
it
well I think you've got the answer it is
you several times in the Bible and the
Bible doesn't tell us precisely what it
is some commentators have said they
think it's a large whale or perhaps a
white shark some even say a sea serpent
which they believed in in those days or
it could be a large alligator I think
you touched it when you said a sea
monster that's as close as we can get
Pastor Brooks do you have a favorite
Bible study program how do we know which
verses to memorize
oh my this does become quite personal I
um I have studied the Bible for many
angles one good way is to read it from
Genesis to Revelation and do it over and
over and over it is the word of God it
is not magic but it is powerful
another way is to study by subjects if
you want to study about the second
coming of Christ look up all the
references that deal with that study
them and make notes and then get
corroborating evidence from Bible
commentaries and that sort of thing
there are many ways to do it find a way
that's good for you now there are guides
they are lessons and if you want to know
about some of those we can tell you
privately one of the best in the world
is called Bible readings for the whole
it has over 300 subjects and the
question and answer form that's easy to
be assimilated and not only that all of
it comes from scripture all the answers
that is
Pastor Brooks if you have been divorced
for several years is it okay to remarry
or is it still considered adultery well
that all depends
if you have never known God's will or
never been a Christian
I'm glad to tell you the Lord takes you
just as you are
like he took the woman at the well
Jesus always took Sinners cleansed them
and then said go and sin no more
now the answer to your question of
course is relative it depends on how
that divorce was gotten and what your
status your spiritual status was at the
time and the status of the individual to
whom you had been married
did they divorce you or was it something
Mutual they had so many questions and
you'd almost have have to have personal
counsel but generally speaking God takes
a sinner as he finds that sinner
washes away his sins and then makes him
a child of God and says go and sin no
more and if you don't want to sin
anymore he says I will give you power to
live right now unto him that is Abel
that's the key word able to keep you
from falling next please
Pastor is there anything in the Bible
Pro or Khan on cremation no there's
nothing in the Bible about creation
about cremation please forgive me
cremation
uh we uh I think reasonably and
justifiably sentimental about our dead
while I stand here right now
my dear wife has traveled to
Pennsylvania one of our favorite aunts
just died
and I feel the pain even now and I know
other members of the family are grieving
death is the common lot of humanity
and we love our loved ones and when they
die we want to honor their memory
and so we feel very sentimental
and sometimes we go to extremes we want
to bury them in very expensive coffins
and mausoleums and then we want to buy
very expensive memorial stones and all
of those things simply because we
cherish the memory of the Dead
but it really doesn't matter in God's
sight how you die or what happens to you
after you die
until the resurrection and make no
mistake about it there is power with God
to bring forth from the dead
all who die in the Lord and in the
second Resurrection those who did not
die in the Lord
so you don't have to worry about that
now from a very pragmatic point of view
more and more people are turning to
Cremation today it saves a barrel of
money and takes very little uh effort
compared to the other to dispose and oh
that sounds so hard of the remains of
the Dead nothing wrong with it now you
need to be careful what you do after
that I I went to a home one day and
there was a beautiful urn and I have an
eye for things beautiful and I commented
about it and the person said oh that's
my husband
now it gave me a little Eerie feeling
I'll be honest with you if I ever did
that I wouldn't want it sitting in my
living room I'd put it somewhere else
this is our final question for tonight
Dr Brooks my husband feels that just
like a man should not dress like a woman
it is wrong for a man to do housework
please comment
you're a husband
now
I don't think it would be fair for you
to go and tell your husband that I said
he ought to do housework
the other night I preached on the home
and I pointed out that if in today's
economy the wife has to work then the
husband has as much responsibility at
home as the wife does they're both
working and you shouldn't take it as one
against the other it's an opportunity to
be together it's an opportunity to have
some of the most beautiful conversations
that you can ever have I do it and I
told you I don't have to do it my
daughter's sitting here she knows I
don't have to do it nobody makes me do
anything in my own
but I do it
and you know what I do it well I'm a a
white tornado
when I come home I can really do a job
on bathrooms and scrubbing and all of
that it keeps my wife Young
and I have I have no problem with it now
if you have a problem I'm not trying to
force you to do anything it's just a
good choice and now if you don't want to
do it just tell your wife I don't want
to do that don't make up these invalid
excuses the Bible says I will stretch
over Jerusalem the lion of Samaria and
the plummet of the House of Ahab and I
will wipe Jerusalem as a man wipeth a
dish
so there seems to be at least some Bible
president for a man helping at home
and in a case it's a good idea and men
and women who do it together have a
little nicer atmosphere in their home
and anything that will do that
ought to be considered positively